el cáncer de pulmón es la principal
causa de muerte por cáncer en malasia
tanto para hombres como para mujeres los
pulmones son dos órganos esponjosos que
se encuentran en el pecho el pulmón
izquierdo está dividido en dos lóbulos o
secciones y el pulmón derecho tiene tres
lóbulos cuando inhala el aire ingresa
por la nariz o boca y se dirige a la
tráquea o tubo aéreo en la karina la
tráquea se divide en dos bronquios y
luego se ramifica en bronquios los más
pequeños los bronquiolos terminan en
diminutos sacos de aire o alvéolos aquí
el oxígeno del aire que inhala se dirige
al torrente sanguíneo y el dióxido de
carbono del cuerpo sale del torrente
sanguíneo
el dióxido de carbono es expulsado del
cuerpo cuando exhala los pulmones están
recubiertos por la pleura una membrana
delgada que los protege y les ayuda a
moverse de un lado a otro mientras
inhala y exhala debajo de sus pulmones
se encuentra el diafragma un músculo
delgado y liso que ayuda a sus pulmones
a expandirse y contraerse mientras
respira los pulmones están conectados a
pequeños grupos de células del sistema
inmunológico llamadas ganglios
linfáticos a través de vasos linfáticos
existen grupos de estos ganglios
linfáticos cerca de los pulmones por
encima de las clavículas y detrás del
esternón como también en otras partes
del cuerpo los vasos linfáticos llevan
bacterias células cancerígenas y otro
material dañino fuera de los pulmones y
otros órganos en un líquido transparente
llamado linfa los ganglios linfáticos
filtran este material fuera de la linfa
el cáncer de pulmón normalmente comienza
en los bronquios pero también puede
comenzar en la tráquea bronquiolos